[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young man
whose girlfriend gave him hiv and his
parents want him to break up with her go
figure we also talked to a young woman
who's engaged in her dad cheated on her
mom and she's scared about infidelity in
her own relationship we talked to a
husband who really wants kids and his
wife doesn't stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john dolone's show hope
you're doing well hope the world's going
well
where you are living
this show we talk about mental health
relationships we talk about friendships
and workplace yeah we talk about
parenting school everything anything
that's going on in your world
give us a shout um if you want to be on
the show go to johndaloni.com
ask a-s-k
some people think it is johndalone.com
and that would be weird
although the guy that
cody's looks like a lumberjack i could
see that mistake if he knew cody cody
runs my world he's the manager that runs
everything for me and
actually that's not true kelly runs my
world
cody does what kelly says um but he
looks like a lumberjack but it's not
johnny.com axe it's ask ask
um don't forget to sign up for the
newsletter go
god i feel like i said my name 11 times
already go to john delaney.com scroll
down to the bottom put in your name
and um we will send you some dope stuff
not dope stuff that's weird we're not in
a hip-hop group we'll send you some cool
things
um
i'd love to be in a hip-hop group
why is it funny
it just sounds like we're going to send
him a paraphernalia
kelly's like yeah
it's not legal yet in tennessee so we
won't be mailing out dope stuff but we
will send you some neat things via email
neat things
that's gonna line them up at the door to
sign up everyone loves neat things
we all love neat things on the internet
they're swell
oh my gosh i've got four applications to
other jobs i hope they come through this
is not working out at all oh my gosh
oh boy all right let's go to tim in des
moines des moines iowa what's up tim
hey john
hey do you call it desmoines or is that
like what lame people call it
uh i think
people who don't speak english cause
that
that was a strong flex tim strong flex i
do speak english
i just think it's funny but i'll call it
des moines
uh so what's up dude how can i help
um
so my question is uh my girlfriend gave
me a
quite serious std and my parents ended
up finding out about this
um they are now against our relationship
saying that it's the way that god is
showing that this relationship is not
meant to be
i've been fighting this
like against my parents
and my question is has
is there too much that has happened for
this relationship to work
uh or am i trying too hard to make it
work
bro there's a lot going on here man
a whole lot
um
before i dig in let's let me just let's
just have a conversation so i get to
know you for a second is that cool okay
yeah um you sound a little bit nervous
are you nervous or is this just weird or
i realize you're calling a stranger
being like okay i got an st eye from
this woman that i love this whole
thing's kind of weird
this is basically the first person
outside of this
uh situation that i've talked to so
gotcha dude i am i'm grateful for the
trust it sounds like there's a lot lot
going on here
um
tell me about you how old are you what
are you for living all that kind of
stuff
uh
27 i'm
going to um
studying nursing okay
and
just about to graduate here
so congratulations on that um do you
live at home
no i i don't okay so
what kind of sti did you get
uh hiv okay so you've got hiv okay so i
was wondering if this was
my first question was why in the world
do your parents know
um
if i'm 27 the last people on planet
earth i would call until i have an sti
is my parents but
hiv is super serious what is your
health prognosis
um it's
um so
i guess the situation gets a little bit
more difficult because
um
my dad does computer diagnostics and he
was able to accidentally kind of find
out i have this
and so i am
accidentally kind of what does that mean
meaning he wasn't expecting it he wasn't
looking for it it was just kind of came
up
when
he was doing that i regularly do
checkups he's a
a doctor oh so he's a doctor at the
place where you went to get checked out
and
he
discovered through the computer system
that his son has hiv
yes it's it's a it's a
alternative medicine that he
does and
so it's it's a very different kind of
for modern medicine so it's
just uh
just the way that he found out um
i just go to my dad always for health
checkups yeah
oh what a mess okay so tell me about
this person that you're dating
um
so
um
i guess
what would you like to know about her
no just tell me about it
well
she's a she's a nurse um
in uh illinois and
um
this is
the second uh
serious relationship she's had
okay uh for me it's
um
maybe the first serious relationship for
me okay um and so
she's i mean she grew up in the
christian family she's
um
does she knowing you knowingly give you
hiv
no she didn't know about it
okay
she the first person you've ever slept
with
yes okay
how long y'all been together
uh we've been uh together for a year now
a year okay
so back to my original question brother
this is just me caring about
somebody i just met like what's your
health prognosis
um so
right now there's
potential that the treatment that
through my dad that
it will go away even though
um
with
so i'm being treated for it that way
um
yes in the place where i work there's a
thousand employees here
i would be willing to bet my truck and
it's not a great car i'm gonna be honest
with you it's not great but i'd be
willing to bet it
that
i'm the most
health practitioner in this building
i'm not a health practitioner i didn't
say that right that i am the most um
homeopathic geeked out nerd when it
comes to that kind of stuff in this
building right
and you have hiv
and i want you to
make sure you go meet with a traditional
practitioner okay
yeah got it
yes
yeah i understand that
i don't want you taking essential oils
and like fermented oats and with the
assumption that hiv is going to go away
right okay and i'm being provocative and
i know that and my friends who are
homeopaths are going to get all over me
i get that
um i don't want you to mess around with
this okay
right
right
um that's a secondary thing
so
to answer your original question brother
i i don't want to get into
faith disagreements with you and with
your parents
i do not believe that
god has given you a terminal illness
because you had premarital sex if that's
the question
but i also am not going to get into a
debate with somebody who has that
particular faith view that's not that's
not an a fight i'm interested in
engaging
um you did have unprotected sex with
somebody right
and
a
consequence of unprotected sex can be
stis
and
can be hiv is that right
okay so
i want to deal with where you are right
now
um
you're 28 27 is that right
yep
so at the end of the day your parents do
not get a vote on who you're dating
do you live at home
i don't i already asked you that no you
don't so they don't get a vote brother
yes
um
is your relationship with the woman that
you love who gave you hiv gonna be
fraught with
so much trauma yeah
is it gonna be
hard to work through that yeah no
question about that
can you i
i've never honestly sat down with
somebody who's in your situation i have
talked to folks numerous folks who got
things like syphilis or gonorrhea or
something like that i have not talked
through somebody in this situation
talked through a bajillion of couples
who get pregnant and their their parents
are are all over them
haven't talked to somebody with
something as serious as this
and my understanding of where we
currently are with in the medical system
with hiv is limited i know there's some
cocktails and stuff that have proven to
be rather remarkable
um
but i i don't know anything about your
medical condition and
like
how what prognosis is how long you have
to live all that kind of stuff
what i'll tell you is
it is not uncommon
for somebody
to feel intimately connected to the
first person they're with despite trauma
despite anything despite a all those
things
so your love for her your
connection to her
is yours
um
let me what are you asking me
um
like am i am i just disregarding the
situation and trying to make something
work that
is not meant to work
i don't think you can i don't think
that's a question worth asking
yeah
i think the question worth asking is
do you want to be with somebody who gave
you hiv
whether unknowingly or knowingly
do you want to be with somebody
who um
does that person treat you i mean it's
all all the normal stuff
does that make sense
yeah
does this person um make you feel whole
does this person make you feel like you
have value does this person love you and
has dedicated their life to serving you
and vice versa
or
are you bonding over trauma and tragedy
oh crap we're in this we might as well
be together forever and make it work at
all cost et cetera
i gotcha i'm telling you
i would have a
heart on this side of the fence again
i've never been on the inside
dating somebody for seven months eight
months and then finding out they gave me
hiv
i would have a hard time leaning into
that relationship
again that is me on this side of it
if i happen to be in that situation i
can't speak to it because i don't have
that experience
but if you walk in going is this meant
to be should i am i wasting my time dude
i can't answer that question for you
why do you want to stay with this person
um
just because
i guess
accept this situation i mean
she respects me she loves me and
we have
trust and i mean i've been trying to
look through kind of all the things that
are supposed to be in the relationship
and
they seem to be all there so okay so
here's what i want you to do have you
all gone to see somebody and talk about
the
like it feels like you're minimizing it
a lot
and maybe my ignorance on the current
state of treatment for hiv is is the
problem here
it feels like you were worried about
whether this relationship's gonna work
and i'm worried about your health
right
and i think it is of utmost importance
if you are looking at this
person and say i want to spend the rest
of my life with him
i we are in it now and i want to be in
it with with her
you all need to go see
some sort of marriage counselor today
this weekend
monday tuesday next week
go see somebody
and say we're both interested in making
this thing work
and we got this big giant
grenade that just went off in the living
room
right and we got to deal with that
right
yeah and i want you to make sure you are
talking to somebody about your health
your health
journey your parents my guess is you and
i could talk for a long long time about
the messages you received growing up
oh yeah and it was probably tough is
that fair
yes okay
um at some point my hope for anybody is
not that it's when
they have a contracted hiv and their
parents are telling them that's god
punishing them for making a bad decision
but here you are
at some point you're going to have to
stand up and disconnect yourself from
that relationship for a season
and ask yourself what do you want to do
professionally what do you want to do
personally
um
how are you going to cut those strings
and get the
the relational iq relational mental
health healing that you need
and then
lean into am this the person i want to
marry
that makes sense
yeah anything you're saying oh go ahead
so you're saying that first i need to
like disconnect from my parents like all
my
decisions and everything and then
lean into the relationship and figure
figure that out
no
tim you're 28 right
right what'd you do before nursing
school
um i just had uh various healthcare jobs
got my bachelor's in nutrition exercise
and health sciences okay
i'm not going to be the guy here that
tells you you've got a disconnect from
your parents but i'm telling you you got
to grow up
right and yeah
that's that's the that's the idea that
i've been
uh
that i've been
or that i had
for i guess in this relationship i did
just tell you to disconnect from your
parents here's what i mean by that not
never talk to them again
not you sound like a guy that's gonna
follow my my words to a t and so i'm
gonna be really clear with you okay and
it's good for me so i'm glad you're
pushing me on this
you are going to have to make some
decisions on your own
you're going to have to deal with your
family trauma you're going to have to
deal with the fact that your parents
have told you that the creator of the
universe is punishing you
yeah and that they don't want their son
next to this
woman who did this thing and what all
that stuff
and you're going to have to reconcile
that with the fact that they love you a
lot my guess is is my guess is that fair
yes okay
you're going to have to grow up
and decide what you want to do
how you want to do it what battles in
your life are worth fighting
what who you're going to take wisdom and
advice from
do you have close guy friends
uh nothing not very many yeah so one of
the cool things about my job is that
people call and trust me with really
heavy stuff
sometimes and this is one of those
things
where
dude if your girlfriend of a year
gave you hiv
and you don't have anyone else to talk
to in the world that should be a giant
red flag for you you've got to get
people in your life that will walk
alongside you
okay
yeah
a guy a stranger on the radio can't be
your first call here
you've got to have people that you trust
you're 28 that are not your parents that
are your friends
that are a counselor that are people you
work with classmates that you trust
and my tells me that there's just you're
gonna have to practice relationships for
a long time so yes i'm gonna i'm going
back on myself again in the same call i
think i've flip-flopped two or three
times
you do need to disconnect from your
parents but that doesn't mean cut them
off that doesn't mean be ugly or rude or
disrespectful
that means that when they say
god is punishing you for what you've
done you must break up with her and move
home immediately
and you don't want to do those things
you say
i am really grateful that you are trying
to love me in the way you're trying to
love me
i'm 28 i live in my own place
i'm gonna stay here
and i'm gonna make some personal
decisions with the help of a counselor
and a buddy or two
a pastor somebody that i trust that i
can be honest with and will walk
alongside me day after day about
my romantic relationships my health care
journey
and what's going to come next for me
and i love you guys and i'm grateful
that y'all are speaking into my heart
that's what i mean by disconnecting they
don't get a vote anymore
i understand okay
um and
you gotta get with you and your
girlfriend gotta give the counselor asap
and you've gotta make a doctor's
appointment if you haven't already have
you seen a traditional medical
practitioner
no please do that
okay
please do that
and i'm not gonna get into your medical
care stuff i i'm not gonna get in all
that other than it says please go see a
traditional doctor okay
please please do that
oh tim
here's how i give you the benefit of
doubt
everything in your world just blew up
your parents your faith your medical
your your health
your relationship with your girlfriend i
get all that in your last year of being
a nurse in the middle of covet
everything in your world is a snow globe
right now just shook up shook up shook
up your gupta cup i get that i get that
i get that
and this call i was not clear on the
skull i'm sorry kind of
caught off guard and then surprised and
then trying to work through
word even start on this deal
you need some professional therapeutic
care today asap you need some
professional medical care today asap
backing all the way up to the moon and
looking down on earth
you're 28 years old brother's time to
grow up
time to grow up
life has happened to you
you made some personal choices in your
life about how you're going to handle
intimacy and sex and how you can be safe
about it and not safe about it
and there's it happened so now you're
gonna live in that reality and you're
gonna work from there
there's not gonna be a linear approach
other than medical care and therapeutic
care for sure
there'll be some really good days some
really tough days and you're going to
have to have some people in your life
that walk alongside you feel free to
call me back after you have some of
these hard conversations brother i'm
here to take your calls and i'll walk
alongside with you
i'm not hearing in your voice that you
get what a huge deal this is
this is not about breaking up with your
girlfriend this is every single thing in
your life is different now
and you're gonna have to start from
square one
thank you so much for the trust brother
tim thank you so much for the call get
some people in your lunch you can talk
to you today that are not your parents
but that will have your best interest
and then we'll walk alongside you give
you wisdom for the long haul
we'll be right back on the dr john
delaney show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance i can't get off work and time
to go see somebody and it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dalloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we're back let's go to laura
in flushing the commode new york what's
up laura i couldn't i'm sorry laura i'm
sorry
hi hey john how are you i'm good i know
your town is named flushing and i made a
komode joke and i'm sorry i couldn't
help it i tried
everybody does that it's okay i know i
don't want to be everybody but i
couldn't help it i would love to live in
a town called flushing that would be so
awesome
it's basically new york city but yeah
[Laughter]
well my name is used to name toilets too
and john so here we go so hey what's up
laura how how can i help
well um first i just want to um thank
you for you know taking my call as
quickly as you did i found you on
youtube literally the same night i
called you and it's just remarkable so
thank you well that's awesome thanks for
calling in thanks for watching youtube i
don't even know how to log into that but
it sounds like it's a fun little uh
thing that that people watch sounds
awesome yeah well that's awesome so
what's up how can i help well um so
basically um
i am in
a i've known my fiance for four years uh
we got engaged um this may i live in new
york city he lives in kentucky
and everything was good up until
two years ago because
okay so i'm 28 years old
i live with my parents they're in the
early 60s they married in the 80s
and
we now me my mom and my sister
we found out that my dad was cheating on
my mom with different women all the
years of
their marriage
the first the first time we found this
out
it was
well at least i wasn't born yet but my
mom found out in 1990 when my sister was
a baby
and and a woman and a woman called the
house and
okay but fast forwarding to today two
years ago um
thanks to the power of the internet we
found out through emails he was emailing
lots of different women he was trying to
hook up with
none of which accepted his offer so he
kept getting turned down to her down
turned down but all
all our lives for me my sister he was
trying to hook up with different women
okay and
and two years ago we found this out
and this has created immense
trust issues between me and my fiance
i do not know how to trust men and
and there's there's more to the story
but i'll let you
what's the more to the story well
so my father is not only
a
um a downright a-hole and a cheater but
he is also a black mailer meaning
when we found out what my dad was doing
he
to my mom at first and myself included
because i live with my parents um we
started to you know say you know how
could you do this
mommy's loved you for for all these
years she's been faithful to you she
cleaned your clothes washed makes your
food etc
and um
at first you know we were telling him
this
and then
my dad decided to try to commit suicide
in front of my mom every chance he got
and this
has been daily sometimes i've had to
call the police
and take him to the hospital and they've
only kept him one night
no medication
nothing and he only does this suicide
thing in front of my mom not me or my
sister or my sister's or my sister or
her husband who lives on the seventh
floor
um
[Music]
and
he doesn't do this in front of me
and this has created immense
trust issues between me and my fiance i
do not know how to trust men and i'm
terrified to get married
and we when we fight and then
his name is daniel uh we fight
every single day is daniel a good man
absolutely
he he doesn't um he hasn't
um he doesn't raise his voice to me
daniel
yeah he so hold on lord
your dad is sick
yes he is
sick
it's a mess
and one of the most devastating things
about
infidelity
especially pervasive ongoing infidelity
that goes over years and years and years
there is the oh my gosh i met somebody
at work and it was three weeks and
suddenly turned into a thing into a
thing there's that
there's the work event one night of
stand
then there's the pervasive
over a series of years
betrayal
there's the betrayal that sucks tears
your soul out from you
but i believe that one of the worst if
not the worst outcome of
that type of betrayal that type of
infidelity
is it causes people to doubt themselves
how did i miss this it makes you feel
crazy
and you have had a working picture of a
dad and i bet if you're honest he wasn't
a great dad either oh no on the contrary
that's right so so
you
everything about him says not safe not
healthy not well not a person of
character all those things
mushed up into one thing
and it has made you feel nuts
why can't this guy act like an adult why
won't this man love me he's my dad
why won't he love my mom
she seems great to me you feel crazy and
you're not
okay
well yeah no um i just i just want to
reiterate um
this has become a total shock to me only
only about my dad only because
he he was a good father to me and my
sister he supported us when whatever we
did
um it's just that his marriage with my
mom was doomed from the start oh not
only because of the infidelities but
because they are just so completely
opposite no no no no no their marriage
was doomed because
they didn't choose both of them
to work on it to stay connected into it
to decide we are both super opposite
we're gonna make this thing work we're
gonna lean into it and i'll give them
the benefit of the doubt they didn't
have the tools the ideas that all the
stuff all the pictures all that stuff
but here's the thing
you're here now
and you're dating a guy named dan who's
a great guy right
for four years
you're engaged to him okay
you have a singular hard chat decision
to make a challenge ahead of you
your body now does not trust men
because the one who was dead
destroyed it
destroyed your trust is that fair can i
just interrupt for a quick second yeah
um my sister's husband like i said they
live on the seventh floor um he he he is
also the same type of person he's
cheated on my sister all the years
they've known each other
and
my sisters the exact same way as my mom
because they now have to keep quiet
otherwise the men in their life
literally try to commit suicide if they
if they don't shut up about about it
so it's not just my father it's my
sister so then you got two of them
yes two men who are very close to you
are
running a great scam and they're not
well
both and
i'm gonna challenge you your parent your
mother and your sister need to get away
from these men these abusive
um
um
gaslighting
men who lack character and who are
incredibly unwell
they need to distance themselves from
them
they can choose not to and say it's
because they're trying to keep them
alive and all those things
but they need to leave that's another
call
i'm going to continue to push back to
right now you
because you can't control them the only
thing on planet earth you can control
laura is
your thoughts and your actions that's it
i'm very well aware of that yeah
that's why i called you i love it i love
it so
your body is going to respond to trust
and intimacy with men
as though it is a terrifying thing
that's going to get you hurt because
that's what it's experienced and that's
fair that your body's trying to take
care of you that way
okay
has daniel done anything to
show you that he is not worthy of your
trust
absolutely not
however i just have to say because of
what has happened
and i'm afraid to trust men so
ardently
i
i keep thinking he thinks he thinks this
cashier is hot he thinks this lady on tv
is hot i i want to be the constant
this constant sex idol then break up
with him
just break up with him i think you
should break up with him and just move
on with your life and be single for the
rest of your life
well i i don't i don't want to do that
okay then if you don't want to do that
and i was being an idiot of course not
do that of course i know it sounded
funny what i just said no no it doesn't
it doesn't it sounds defeatist and i get
it
you've earned a fetish
life has thrown you crap
your brother-in-law sucks
your dad sucks
and i know that sounds mean to say it
like that but it's true
i know it's true
dan doesn't
and
you have those thoughts and they are
real and they pop into your head and
then when they pop in you have a choice
and that is am i going to meditate on
these am i going to try to become them
am i going to try to live into them am i
going to throw them on my fiancee who i
love
or am i going to heal from these things
so that over time i'm able to trust dan
he is going to be my refuge in this
world of insanity
that's the choice you have
otherwise you are choosing to make
yourself miserable and by proxy make him
miserable and i don't think he deserves
it do you
no and the fights have become so
frequent he he was supposed to visit new
york in november and he keeps putting it
off because he's afraid i'm gonna start
screaming at him are you
yes you are
what do you mean
think of it this way
your dad dumped a bucket of crap on you
and every time you're around dan you
take some of it and throw it at him
just because he might he might have some
too
and if i'm him i don't want to be around
that
he's probably trying to love the woman
of his life the best he can through
trauma and through this these
revelations
and you're hitting him for it
i have to admit he has been very
extremely not very extremely patient
through all of this
laura do you want to hurt
forever
no okay i don't
every time you scream every time you
yell every time you start a fight
it's a choice to be miserable
every time
every time you hold secrets back from
daniel it's a choice to
um
put a wedge in your relationship
you know what's crazy though there are
no secrets between us i i have this
weird thing about me where i don't know
how to
lie it's just crazy
in a previous episode we recorded
recently
we talked about um
there's a difference between no secrets
and being honest and over sharing being
being weaponizing truth
there is something
spoiler alert your husband's going to
find other women attractive throughout
his life it's going to happen
he's going to see somebody be like wow
beautiful
you're gonna have to get over that
and you're gonna see people and think
they're super good looking too
i actually won't believe it or not i i
know myself i i won't you're super super
incorrect on that but it's cool you can
live in that fantasy right now that's a
different phone call you for sure will
and that's okay that's not infidelity
that means you don't love each other
that means you're human
what i'm hearing over and over and over
laura
is you don't want to heal right now and
you don't have to that's your
prerogative you want to not hurt
and i believe that
but you don't want to do the hard hard
work to heal from what has happened to
you
you don't
you want to rage and unfortunately a guy
you love
and if who wants to marry you
is the target of your rage
and if i'm him i'm not sticking around
for that
we're not married yet i don't have to
i'm out
because i'm just trying to love you the
best i can and you're taking it out on
me over and over and over again
your body is right to be scared of men
they've hurt you and those you love
fair
daniel has not
you have to come up to a come up to a
place in your relationship where you can
say hey i'm my heart is racing right now
as though you've done something and i
know you haven't
but i'm feeling super anxious right now
about our relationship
and because you've been through trauma
and he loves you he can say
thank you for sharing that with me i
love you i'm committed to you i'll never
cheat on you never have and you go
okay thank you
that's it
no screaming no fights no anger no rage
no none of that stuff
that's not gonna solve or heal or help
anything
nothing it's a choice to stay in the
sewer system that your brother-in-law
and dad drag you down into
now
daniel's going to get some crap on him
because he's going to hug you
not because you're going to throw it at
him
and when you hug somebody who's hurting
you get their blood and guts and crap on
you that's part of love that's what love
is he doesn't deserve to be have it
thrown at him
you have to decide
do i want to have a healthy marriage do
i want to work through my fear of men do
i want to honor and love this guy daniel
who honors and loves me do i want joy in
my life or do i just want to be
miserable
you are not trapped you're making some
choices
hard call laura
i don't think you're ready i think
you're still too angry and still too
full of rage
[Music]
but i wish you peace i'll tell you what
i wish you peace
i really do we'll be right back on the
dr john dolan show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back this show has been
an adventure thus far hey derek in
orlando what's up my brother
hey john i'm good how are you
i don't you know what man
it's awesome i'm doing awesome you
i i am excited to be talking to you i am
more excited to be talking to you trust
me so what's up dude how can i help
hey well first i wanna say i appreciate
everything the show is doing for
this generation and just in general i
feel like i relate to the show on so
many levels a weakness for sour gummies
i own a strat and a les paul so
like it's like the devil and the angel
on both show on either shoulder
i know you can love it or hate it but
but that's where it's at well good for
you brother thank you so much man what's
up dude
hey so
my wife and i want kids and we've been
talking about starting for years now
probably about five years
but navigating that with the nature of
my wife's job coupled with depression
she's struggled with throughout our
marriage
is contributing to a lot of anxiety for
her and preventing us from being able to
move forward in that regard i know her
concerns are valid
so how do i best love and support her as
she struggles through those anxieties
while still kind of validating my own
disappointment with these things kind of
preventing us from being able to move
forward and
you know not necessarily being where i
thought we would be at this point that's
awesome man that's a great question
derek um what's your wife do
what what about her job she can have
kids
uh it's not so much that she can't have
kids she's a performer and an
entertainer so she does
acting singing dancing
and the big concern is kind of the
physical toll that a pregnancy might
take the bouncing back from
a pregnancy the concern that maybe she
won't bounce back or maybe there'll be a
complication or
you know her physical appearance will
change significantly to the point where
she doesn't get to do that anymore and
it's such a large part of her and she
drives so much passion from it
uh
that that idea
scares her to death
so she doesn't want kids
i i don't she dehumanly tells me that
that she does
but these anxieties are so strong
that it's
it's uh
you know it it's gripping to her i i
mean i can tell even just in the
conversations that we have when it comes
up that
there's this downward spiral that
happens with this idea that like i may
not i may lose this part of myself yeah
that has been
such a strong
source of her identity and rightly so
she's incredibly talented sure very
capable
um
this one's hard man and i'm gonna i'm
gonna be upfront and honest with you
best i can okay this one's hard
um
man
she's trapped in a fear cycle right now
that is gonna be tough to escape from
and
this isn't just for entertainers this is
also for lawyers and this is not only
it's it's
women carry the burden of this fear
cycle but men do too
um it's being a lawyer it's being a tv
show producer it's being
an executive of any sort a
um
here's the thing that a lot of parents
don't wrap their head around
people before they become parents
everything about who you are
before you have kids changes after you
have kids all of it
priorities
body
thoughts
what brings you joy what used to bring
you joy what doesn't bring all of it
everything changes and it's terrifying
scary one of the biggest
cha
problems is the word i'll use one the
biggest problems i see couples make when
they have their first kit is they try to
recreate they try to
re-drag their past into the future
we could just have sex during a lunch
break on a random tuesday you can't do
that when you have a kid sometimes
we could just pack up and leave town on
a weekend and not think you can't do
that when you have a kid
everything changes
um getting that next promotion sometimes
isn't that cool anymore it's cool
but it's really cool hanging out my kid
or i don't want to hang out with my kid
it's boring and it's not as fun as i
thought all this everything changes
that's what i'm saying
that fear feels
i think if your wife was doing another
job that fear would still be there it's
what i'm saying
okay i think this is more about kids
than it is about being an actress and i
could be way off and i'm not talking to
her i'm talking to you
um
i know too many actresses too many
people in in the profession that
have multiple children and you make it
work and
yes you age and yes your body changes
and sometimes it changes
everybody changes everything the id how
about this the idea that
uh how old is she now
uh she's 30 now okay
she's going to be different at 33.
she's going to be different 35. she'll
be different at 40.
differences in her body and her
abilities and her
appearance those things are all going to
happen to all of us whether we have kids
or not
now i don't want to undermine actresses
and actors especially actresses have a
different type of pressure it's real i
get that
but in the same
let's take acting off the table let's
take my job for instance i i have a lot
of opportunities to go speak all over
the country at corporate events private
events all kind of stuff
in one breath i can say i really want to
spend more time with my kids i really do
and when justin who handles all of the
the speaking contracts calls and says
hey i got another one for you for this
much money and i go yeah i'm in
what i have said what i've demonstrated
is that i want money more than i want to
spend time with my kids right now
that's not i'm not going to judge that's
a fact that's what i just did
or i could say
i want to spend more time right now with
my kids right now so i'm going to turn
this speaking gig down
it's an either or proposition
and
the only way i have seen through that
i've been able to navigate that is
through the like what my friend christy
wright called this it's the seasons
it's to say this season
i want to pay this stuff off and this
season i don't want to have a mortgage
in this season i'm going to pile up cash
and so the cost of that is going to be
time with my family and we're all on the
same page we're all talking about it
then as you mentioned earlier this
picture you had that looks different
we're all on the same page about that
looks like
right now your wife can say she wants
kids and that's cool
but she doesn't she wants to be an
actress
and she wants to keep the picture of
being an actress alive as long as
possible because she's scared about
what's going to do to her
and there's i'm telling you right now
there's deeper fears than that that i
think you'll need to go talk to a
marriage counselor and talk through
i think there's deeper things here than
that
um
there's just too many people in the
profession that have kids that
things are great you know what i mean
yeah no i 100 agree i
so so we both have have been talking to
therapists individually and then reading
through
um like for example we started reading
the uh adult children of emotional
images yeah good for you dude like
yeah like for one chapter in like she's
teary eyed yeah i mean
this is this is her and not i think
you're absolutely right in the sense
that there's i mean there are people who
are peers with her in the roles and the
capacities that she's doing who do have
kids yeah it's it's possible absolutely
what what do i do
i mean what what can i do in in those
scenarios in those conversations i mean
i can't imagine that saying back to her
is like yeah you're right it will be
completely different it will
like you probably will lose this or
like i can't imagine that's going to be
helpful but do i need to bring that kind
of dose of reality to it it's it's
when you phrase it like loss you will
lose this
um that's a scarcity mindset
it's not looking at every single thing
you're gonna gain
and it's looking at there is a finite
amount of this and if i don't have that
everything is over
and that's you can't do that kind of
math with kids
you can't do that kind of math with
family expansion you can do that kind of
math with healing
uh in the in the previous call when i
was just talking to that young woman
about
she's got so much rage in her because
what her dad did to her mom
that she can't at this moment let that
go enough to not lose her current fiance
because she's so full of rage
so full of rage and anger
there is it comes these moments are
these either-or propositions and what
she doesn't understand is
if she let go of that rage
and turned to and accepted love and
worked hard on love she has no idea how
good that would feel right now it's all
about safety and protection and your
wife's in a similar situation
she's got the whole idea of being an
actress and an entertainer it's all
scarcity mindset there's one role and
500 people trying to get that role
that's just the nature of that business
i'm in that business it's it's tough
it's hard to live into
um
non-scarcity mindsets right that
everybody wins on these deals
and this idea that man i don't care who
you are when you're 30 your skin looks
different than when you're 20 your body
looks different when you're 40
dude homie it all goes sideways right
it just it just happens and that's why i
don't think this has to do with this
so what i've what i've seen in these
kind of situations and i've i've mostly
seen this in academic situations i have
a friend of mine she's an incredible
scholar her husband's incredible scholar
they have lost out on jobs because she
is quote unquote a breeder
she is somebody who had kids and wasn't
totally dedicated to her
um academic
slice
they called her a breeder for crying out
loud okay
yeah um
what
i've seen this over and over and
ultimately
what people try to do is they start
trying to solve the kid question do we
have a kid not have a kid we have a kid
another kid that's not the issue the
issue is i've got to be at peace with
who i am where i'm headed where i'm
going with my spouse what do we want
this thing to look like five years three
years six years down the road and we're
going to take this in seasons what's
this season going to look like
let's be on the same page about let's do
six months of going all in
or let's do
12 months of going all in
and then let's reevaluate and see where
your career is at where my heart is with
having kids where your heart's having
kids and let's be honest about that
season but it it's you have to do
brother you gotta let your picture go
you gotta let that sucker go it's not
gonna be what it was you thought you
have two kids by now and you're 30. you
don't okay
you're gonna have to grieve that picture
it's not it's not happening it's not
reality cool let's get intentional about
making a new one
and let's get really intentional about
healing because your wife is scared
about other things and it's coming out
with working kids
and anybody listening to this wrestling
about this conversation you gotta step
away from the kid thing because it
becomes the proxy war it's not the real
challenge here does she have a tough
tough road growing up
yeah yeah absolutely and that's why i
think a lot of this
the validation that she receives from
work there you go is
exactly where like adapts with the loss
yeah i think that is that's where the
loss is it's not the field it's not the
profession it's the validation the
success yeah the success and the
validation that she's had there um
because she didn't get a lot of that
growing up um
so i think it's good to affirm that's
real it's real that validation's real
um
it feels real it's not it's fleeting and
it will go away soon all right they'll
find it next the next darling and it'll
be on to the next
um
if i'm you and this is my wife and we're
working through this together
i want to back all the way out of the
kid conversation and ask where are we
headed how can we heal from these
childhood wounds how can we make some
decisions about what kids are going to
look like and then we got to put some
stuff on the calendar
and we've got to be highly intentional
about it
there will come a moment probably be
best to have a counselor in the room
when somebody calls her on
the math that she's trying to do that's
not working i really really want kids
and i really really want this well you
gotta it's gonna cost you one or the
other
and by the way it's not you can be both
but there will be a season right there
will be seasons of shifting and change
um somebody's gonna have to call her on
that
waiting until y'all are in a fight or
into a hard disagreement or everybody's
crying or have tears that's not the
season to do that that's not the moment
to do that does that make sense
yeah that does
um
ultimately
go ahead go ahead
oh i was just gonna ask can i ask you
one more question about like this idea
of grieving the idea that you know i had
a picture in my head it's not there yeah
and like processing through that would
you
would you say to go all the way through
this idea of like grieving the idea
because i've had my you know or what
moment you know of like let's say this
doesn't happen
these take years and years to get
through and and ultimately at the end of
the day the decision is like you know
what
it's just not gonna happen
yeah um and i've had that or what
conversation in my head like would you
leave her and go marry somebody else so
you can have kids
exactly right and and like i'm just
i've made
the vows that i made to her were not
conditional upon that you know and
that's that's where i stand with it but
um
do i go through the entire process of
like grieving the entire idea right now
and if it does work out great
then you're not grieving that you're
never gonna have kids you're grieving
that i had this expectation right here
and it it's not
and what you're trying to do is to get
your body to stop reacting as though
something's on fire
it's not it's already burned down
yeah you know what i mean
so there's something about
when somebody calls you and says hey
your house is on fire
there is a part of your body that goes
into defcon i gotta get there and get
the stuff out
your body responds differently when
someone calls you says hey i'm sorry
there's a hurricane you lost everything
everything's ash
that's a sorrow that's not a response
that is the depths of grief not fight or
flight
right now your body's in fight or flight
because you're still trying to make this
thing happen and it's not
it's past you're 20 you're 30 years old
you thought you'd have two kids but now
you don't
and so there's something about
acknowledging the present the reality of
it and it's gonna hurt man it's a
reality sucks it's i mean just sitting
there being like
and then there's a period in that
sentence and then the real question is
we're not going back i'm already 30. i
still don't have two kids
i don't have four kids running around
here the real question is i'm holding a
pen
what am i going to write next and what
are we going to write next and the good
thing for you derek because you've
already gone through the or what will i
leave her the answer is no
and so now it's about can we make this
work
i want to know are we going to have
children
and it is not about being an actress
that is that's the proxy it's not
there's something going on deeper than
here deeper than that and it probably
has to do with her interaction with her
parents whether that was trauma abuse
neglect all those things combined
healing there will be really important
and then having an honest truthful
conversation about
man everything changes in the
entertainment industry especially when
you are actress when you're a dancer
when you're
a dude movement that's a young kid's
game man and or you transition to
different roles that look different that
move on different all stuff changes and
it's just being honest about seasons
what seasons we're in with what changes
are coming
whether we have kids or not and then
what is a kid actually going to do to
that situation
i just know too many actresses that are
awesome awesome awesome look good kids
too many people in front of cameras that
do great stuff they're incredible
but it's easy to get trapped in that
scarcity mindset especially when you're
working from a place of trauma derek
your wife is lucky to have you in your
life that you love her
um i'm gonna suggest not talking about
kids for a season let's get back to
healing because that kid's just adding a
lot of pressure let's get back to
healing this childhood stuff healing
this relationship you grieve your stuff
and let's paint a picture about where
we're headed and let's be really clear
about putting stuff on the calendar if
we don't have this by 31 then we're
going to try this and we're going to try
that here's our combined goals here
and let's move forward there
thank you so much for calling me i'm
proud of you for doing work with
counseling too man that is incredible
awesome awesome awesome
during a break zach who's running the uh
the youtube channel brought this in
all right this song's kinda on the nose
it's not about you derek okay i'm just
letting you know it's gonna sound like
i'm calling you out it's not it's just
that zach brought this in here before we
even talked
but it just does sound kind of on the
nose so if i was you were sitting here
i would put my arm around you'd be like
bro it's not about you
the song is off the 19th it's an actual
killer song it's one of my favorites man
1973 self-titled aerosmith record and
the song is dream on derek we're not
telling you to dream on kind of no we
kind of are right no
no we're not we're not
here's the song dream on it goes like
this zach filling in
great tune man
every time i look in the mirror all
these lines on my face getting clear the
past is gone and it went by like dust to
dawn isn't that the way
everybody's got their dues in life to
paint yeah this one really is on the
nose
yeah i know nobody knows where it comes
and where it goes i know it's
everybody's sin you got to lose
to know how to win
dream on
yeah derek dream on brother until a
dream come true
man she's lucky to have you and we're
lucky to have you america right here on
the dr john dolone show